ahora vamos a estudiar la estructura
molecular de los triglicéridos pringles
serios a quienes por cierto en la vida
diaria les llamamos grasas grasas que es
una palabra a la que a veces se le tiene
un poco de miedo pero como vamos a ver
son esenciales para la vida y bueno a
las grasas en su estado líquido también
se le llama aceite es el término más
técnico es triglicéridos y de hecho es
el término que vas a escuchar en los
consultorios de los doctores pero
también se le puede llamar de otra forma
también se le puede llamar tri y voy a
escribir cada parte de la palabra con un
color distinto ok esto es 3
así el glicerol 3
glicerol y de hecho me gusta más este
nombre porque tiene más sentido
una vez que dividimos a la molécula en
partes ok trias y el glicerol ahora
cuando decimos triglicéridos realmente
estamos diciendo grasas o bueno
generalmente cuando las personas están
hablando de grasas están hablando de
triglicéridos cuando te haces unos
exámenes para ver cómo estás del
colesterol o cuando tus papás van a
checarse el colesterol van y se hacen un
estudio de triglicéridos que lo que hace
es medir cuál es la concentración de
grasa en la sangre pero bueno ahora
vamos a ponernos a pensar en que es un
triglicéridos
por aquí tenemos las moléculas
constituyentes de un triglicéridos
esta molécula de la izquierda es un
glicerol glicerol por aquí podemos ver
que el glicerol tiene una cadena de 3
carbonos y cada uno de esos carbonos
tiene un grupo hidroxilo aunque hay un
grupo
en general con que una molécula tenga
por lo menos un grupo hidroxilo esa
molécula es un alcohol así es que esta
molécula definitivamente es un alcohol
de hecho como tiene estos tres grupos
hidroxilo xa veces también se les llama
trío y además se considera un azúcar
alcohólico lo que también conocidos como
poli alcoholes pero vamos a dejarlo por
aquí como azúcar alcohólico azúcar
alcohólico podemos ver claramente porque
es alcohólico aquí tenemos los grupos o
h y si llegáramos a beber una solución
de glicerol veríamos que tiene un sabor
dulce y es posible que ya estés
familiarizado con el término glicerol o
por lo menos con uno de sus sinónimos
glicerina porque hay una canción muy
famosa de buzz que se llama glicerina
así es que aquí tenemos nuestra molécula
de glicerol y se transforma en un
triglicéridos
cuando reacciona con tres ácidos grasos
así es que estas tres moléculas de aquí
son ácidos grasos porque este de aquí es
un ácido graso este de aquí es otro
ácido graso y lo mismo este de aquí
también es un ácido graso ahora porque
decimos que son grasos y en particular
porque decimos que son tal cual ácidos
grasos bueno pues por aquí tenemos estas
cadenas de carbonos que por cierto puse
aquí estos tres puntos suspensivos
porque aquí pueden tener diferentes
números de carbonos de acuerdo con las
investigaciones de salman que pueden
llegar a tener hasta casi 30 carbonos
por ahí de los altos veintes en la
mayoría de los sistemas biológicos estas
cadenas suelen tener un número par de
carbonos y en la mayor parte de la
biología de los animales estas cadenas
suelen tener entre 16 y 20 carbonos y
como generalmente es un número par
entonces en los animales estas cadenas
suelen tener 10
6 18 o 20 carbonos ahora todos los
enlaces que dibujé por aquí son enlaces
simples así es que tenemos la mayor
cantidad de hidrógenos posibles pero por
supuesto aquí también podríamos tener
enlaces dobles y vamos a hablar más de
eso cuando estemos hablando de grasas
saturadas o insaturadas por aquí tenemos
estas cadenas de carbono las cuales son
hidrofóbicas no se van a disolver bien
en el agua y por eso es que algunas
personas dicen que es grasoso ahora del
lado izquierdo por lo menos como dibuje
yo estas moléculas de este lado tenemos
un grupo car box y lo carbón si lo y
además es ácido ok porque es súper fácil
deshacerse de este hidrógeno aunque
bueno debería de decir protón de
hidrógeno porque si este oxígeno se
quedara con estos dos electrones sería
muy fácil repartir esta carga negativa
con este otro oxígeno de acá
y así es que es súper sencillo
deshacerse de este protón de hidrógeno
lo cual hace que esta molécula sea ácida
y de ahí es de donde viene la parte de
ácido graso ahora por otro lado todas
estas cadenas pueden ser diferentes ok
por ejemplo esto podría ser una cadena
de 18 carbonos está una cadena de 16
carbonos y está una de 20 carbonos con
algunos enlaces dobles por ahí ok
estas tres cadenas pueden ser diferentes
pero bueno ahora vamos a ver cómo se une
y lo vamos a ver paso por paso así como
si estuviéramos viendo una de esas
películas de los 80 de robots algo así
como bol chrome pero bueno lo que está
sucediendo por aquí y lo que vamos a ver
es básicamente un repaso de la síntesis
por deshidratación pero lo que pasa por
aquí es que este oxígeno tiene dos pares
de electrones libres bueno en realidad
todos estos oxígenos de los grupos
hidroxilo
tienen sus dos pares de electrones y
entonces nos podemos imaginar como éstos
van pasando por ahí y chocan justo de la
forma adecuada y forman un enlace ok
porque este carbono tiene una carga
parcial positiva tiene tres enlaces con
oxígeno y el oxígeno es un átomo super
electro negativo no crea yo entonces
este par de electrones libres si las
moléculas chocan de la forma adecuada se
pueden usar para formar un enlace con
este carbono que tiene una carga parcial
positiva y justo mientras está pasando
esto este enlace se puede soltar ok este
oxígeno puede llegar y decir oye tú ya
estás formando un enlace con otro
oxígeno así es que ya no necesitas a
estos electrones yo me los voy a quedar
o mejor aún voy a usar esos electrones
para capturar algún protón de hidrógeno
y formar un enlace con él
bueno estas dos cosas pueden suceder en
cualquier orden ok se puede formar este
enlace primero pero el punto es que aquí
estamos formando una molécula de agua
ahora este es un repaso muy general
visto muy por encima pero puedes ver
esto con más detalle en química orgánica
y puede suceder tres veces también puede
suceder por aquí este oxígeno se queda
con estos dos electrones que tanto
quiere y puede llegar a usarlo para
formar un enlace con algún protón de
hidrógeno o también puede suceder al
revés que llegue este protón de
hidrógeno y este grupo hidroxilo se vaya
con el protón de hidrógeno y justo
mientras el oxígeno se está llevando
estos dos electrones se forma este otro
enlace de aquí hay muchas formas en las
que esto puede suceder pero pues esta es
la idea general y finalmente sucede esto
una tercera vez se forma un enlace entre
este oxígeno y este
del grupo carbón y lo que también forma
parte de este grupo car box y lo y una
vez más este oxígeno se queda con los
dos electrones de este enlace y
probablemente lo comparte con un protón
de hidrógeno y otra vez aquí se formó
una molécula de agua y aquí también se
está formando una molécula de agua así
es que estamos produciendo tres
moléculas de agua y de hecho por eso se
llama síntesis por deshidratación
ok porque estamos perdiendo moléculas de
agua para que se formen estos enlaces y
ahora cómo se va a ver esto después de
que se formen estos enlaces bueno pues
vamos a ir un poquito hacia abajo pues
este enlace verde es este enlace verde
de aquí y este segundo enlace verde de
aquí
este enlace de por acá y finalmente este
último enlace verde de aquí está por acá
es este enlace verde de aquí ahora como
lo teníamos dibujado por acá estos
oxígenos todavía no se deshacían de
estos hidrógenos sin embargo que se
deshagan de ellos podría haber sucedido
antes o después o al mismo tiempo la
química no es tan limpia y precisa pero
si yo quisiera podría dibujar por aquí a
estos hidrógenos y entonces estos
oxígenos tendrían una carga positiva
pero en cualquier momento nos puede
pasar que llegue una molécula de agua y
se lleve a alguno de estos hidrógenos
aunque haya si es que pueden llegar tres
moléculas de agua y llevarse a los
hidrógenos y los oxígenos entonces ya no
tendrán esta carga positiva y entonces
nos quedaríamos con esta molécula de
aquí ahora recordemos que al hacer estos
enlaces se producen tres moléculas de
agua
y aquí tenemos una
y ahora esta molécula de aquí si
ignoramos estas tres moléculas de agua
esta molécula es un triglicéridos y
vamos a escribir su nombre otra vez por
aquí aunque mejor vamos a escribir su
nombre más técnico tree hill así el
glicerol glicerol y ya sabemos de dónde
viene la parte de glicerol viene de que
aquí tenemos glicerina y glicerol
tenemos esta columna de glicerol pero
ahora a qué se refiere esta parte de
acil bueno pues resulta que hay un grupo
funcional que es el grupo asilo en el
que tenemos un grupo carbón y lo que
puede estar unido a alguna cadena
orgánica a la que le vamos a llamar r y
luego está enlazado a alguna otra cosa
ok
este es un grupo asilo y tenemos tres
grupos así los este es uno de los grupos
asilos
este es otro grupo asilo y este también
es un grupo asilo cada uno de ellos
tiene un grupo carbón y lo enlazado a
una cadena orgánica y a un oxígeno y
cada uno de estos está enlazado con un
oxígeno lo cual nos hace repasar a otro
grupo funcional cuando tenemos un
carbono en un grupo carbón y lo que está
enlazado a alguna otra cadena orgánica
por un lado y por el otro está enlazado
a un oxígeno que está enlazado a otra
cadena orgánica si tenemos esta
estructura decimos que tenemos un esther
y como podemos ver tenemos tres ustedes
por aquí tenemos aquí un tester tenemos
aquí otro externo
y otro esther así es que no solo estamos
aprendiendo acerca de los triglicéridos
o los tres así el glicerol es osea de
las grasas
esas son simplemente tres palabras
distintas para la misma cosa no sólo
estamos aprendiendo de eso sino que
también estamos repasando un poco estos
grupos funcionales y además también
vemos de dónde proviene 3
así el glicerol ok glicerol viene de
esta columna glicerol y tenemos aquí
estos tres grupos así los que permiten
que se unen estos tres ácidos grasos y
bueno a esto es a lo que nos referimos
cuando hablamos de grasa esto es la
grasa y aquí tenemos dos fotos de grasa
ok este es aceite de coco que está más
abajo de su punto de fusión por lo tanto
está en un estado sólido y este de acá
la verdad no me acuerdo qué tipo de
aceite es
está más allá de su punto de fusión y
por eso está en su forma líquida y se le
llama simplemente aceite pero los dos
están formados por un ponche de
triglicéridos ahora si pudiéramos ver
esas moléculas todas tendrían esta misma
estructura general y la única diferencia
sería que estos ácidos grasos tendrían
un número diferente de carbonos y de
enlaces dobles